what if you were dying from thirst and
hunger would you give your iman up your
faith up in order
to survive probably not probably not
because you'd rather die
in hunger and thirst than give up your
religion right this is how much we value
our faith it's priceless brothers and
sisters let me introduce you to norway
this is a european country where the
vast majority of people have become
irreligious there are 200 000 muslims of
a population of about 5 million and most
of these 200 000 muslims have no idea
how to explain islam to their non-muslim
friends and neighbors but that needs to
change allah sent his messenger to call
people to eternal success and that is
why muslims in norway are now
establishing a masjid and our center to
enhance the norwegian tawa but they
cannot do this alone we need to support
them if you donate to the schools you
will insha allah reap the rewards of
thousands of muslims coming back to
islam and many of those will become
dwight and invite to islam
you will share in the reward for all
those shahadas and good deeds to come in
so click the link and donate now and
share the video for extra reward
how are you guys doing there is one
hadith which is a very special hadith
which is very pertinent to the issues
relating to gender now especially in the
modern age after the enlightenment
period after renaissance after all these
times
and different kind of ideologies have
emerged the question is to what extent
have those ideologies especially in the
west had an impact
on human society now that's a very
important question both for religious
audiences and non-religious audiences
i came across this hadith in bukhari and
actually there are lots of hadith which
corroborate this hadith it's called
torokh different
pathways of hadith
talking about a very interesting
incident and i regard this hadith from
my very limited knowledge of hadith
as probably the most telling hadith
of gender relations
in islam or in the 7th century period
now why is this important for
religious people or non-religious people
muslim audiences and non-muslim
audiences alike
because one question that has kind of
plagued our imagination has been to what
extent
have ideologies the like of say feminism
second third wave feminism any type of
feminism has an impact on human
behavior to what extent has it actually
shaped what men or women do to what
extent have it has it shaped societies
and gender relations
and i think this hadith is very
important in answering that question now
i'm not going to be
giving you an exact word for word uh
narration of this hadith but i am going
to be spelling it out for you in kind of
paraphrased terms and send give you a
link in the description box of the
entire hadith although i may say as well
that this hadith has different
narrations but this one is in bukhari
ibn abbas who was
the torja man of the quran
the prolific sahabi that wanted to know
every little thing about
the quran he went to um
who as many of you will know is the
second caliph
after the death of the prophet muhammad
and after abu bakr and also one of the
best friends of the prophet muhammad
he went to him because he wanted to know
the meaning of an ayah of the quran in
chapter number 66 where it said in tatum
if you both repent to allah then allah
has made it so that you may do so and
this was a verse in chapter 66 that i'm
not best wanted to know who these two
were referring to so he went to um
and then um
narrated the story to him so that hadith
is narrated by ibn abbas
and
ahmad al-khattab started by saying
something very interesting
he says
[Music]
he said that we the people of quraish
who are a people
who used to dominate our wives
when we went to the medina
the people the ansar they were
were people that their wives used to
dominate them
now i found this very interesting very
surprising i have to be honest the first
time i came across this hadith it made
me think
this is
this is a 7th century audience this is
at least a thousand
300 and something odd years before
feminism could even be
referred to as such
and there is this phrasiology very
gendered phraseology being used
that we were a people that we used to
dominate our wives and these people of
al-ansar who are another
group of people were a group of people
he's saying
their wives dominated them
and he said
he narrates the story
of going to his wife
i went to my wife
and he was speaking to her
about
the attitudes of medina society
and she answered back
to um
he was a very strong character very
assertive character very extroverted
character extremely confident person
he was a fair man actually a feared man
a big man physically big and a big
personality
and remember he was just saying that you
know we were the people that used to
dominate
our wives
and his wife now is answering him back
so he said
are you answering me back
and his wife
wife returned and she said
you know
actually
you know the prophets why even the
prophets wives who are meant to be like
you know she doesn't say this but who
are in islam meant to be the epitome
of you know they even they
jordan
that used to they used to leave off the
prophet
withdrawal from the prophet muhammad
from the
night from the day into the night
meaning they used to give him the cold
shoulder they used to withdraw from him
and he was bewild he was completely
befuddled and bewildered and bedazzled
and shocked and
by this uh comment so oh he got
triggered you want to put it in that he
got triggered by that
because remember
was the wife of the prophet muhammad one
of the wives of the prophet muhammad
so he says
when he heard that it's like everything
switched off he put on his clothes
i got my my clothes and i put it on me
and he went to
his daughter
and he said to his daughter he said to
her
is it true
that one of you i.e one of the wives of
the prophet used to
leave the the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
from the night to from the day into the
night
not from the night into the day but from
the day into the night meaning it's not
talking about marital relations or
anything like that because that would be
a different level of
transgression which that we have no
evidence ever happened by the way but
anyway
is it the case that you should do
something like that
she says vietnam she says yes
he said whoever does anything like that
she lost his failure
and then he was triggered already so
imagine he's talking to his own daughter
and by the way this shows us it gives us
a glimpse i don't want to make too much
commentary at this point because i'll
comment on this afterwards
of how
the father-in-law
deals with the son-in-law a pious son
albert this one the most pious
son-in-law
he got triggered on behalf of the
son-in-law in this case is
the prophet muhammed who he loved the
most
who he loved the most
he said
you think
don't ever do that he says whoever's
done that is a failure
and what about your friend he's talking
about aisha
who's who is known another wife of the
prophet
that she is
more beautiful than you anyway
and she's more beloved to the prophet
muhammed
so he he saw that she was being jairia
she was being bold
so he was bold with her she was
triggering him he triggered her
and this is in many ways the right way
to advise
a woman
who is disrespecting her husband with
all due respect now we see a lot of
people
they see that the woman is complaining
and withdrawing from the husband not
giving him his rights and they egg her
on they push her to do some more yeah do
it more this is the father of the he
loves her so much
yeah
as the quran says
if you speak then speak the truth and
even if it is someone close to you so
this was the manhattan
and the way of
so he went after that to see the prophet
muhammed himself and he had a man
guarding the door his name was
he was guarding the door and he was by
himself
because his wives had told him that the
the the the hafsah had told him that the
prophet muhammad had been like secluded
by himself and this was going to give us
another lesson by the way which is a
very important lesson which we don't
hear enough of i'll tell you what
happened
at first he didn't allow anybody in
including umar but eventually
he
come into the house
so ahmad came into the house and the
first question he asked
he asked him did you divorce your wives
and he said no
he didn't divorce his wife so he said
allahu akbar ahmad was celebrating
because in reality he doesn't want to
see his daughter or any of the other
mothers of the believers be divorced
so he was elated by the fact that he
there was no divorce that took place
and then um
he said the same kind of thing that he
was saying to ibn abbas in the beginning
of generation he and i want you to pay
attention to the psychological cues here
they're very important because they
relate to the gender discussions
that i have happening now not just from
feminists but from these red pill and
all these kind of things
is an eye opener to the man hedge of the
prophet of how he dealt with these
issues
before the the existence of these
ideologies
so
stated the same thing as he stated
before
he says
we are people we the people of quraish
were people that we used to dominate our
wives
when the people of al-ansar their wives
used to dominate them
so he's saying the same thing the
prophet's reaction to this he just
smiled literally
he just smiled he said he just smiled
so he didn't really engage with that he
said yes you know
to be honest that was not the the
response of the prophet muhammad
he stated that he went to his daughter
and he told her what he told her you
know that is more beloved than all the
kind of things i told you before and
again it said that the prophet sallam
he merely smiled he did not
engage
with omar
and then
he made dua a supplication to the
prophet
muhammad because he was sleeping on this
kind of straw and he said the people of
you know the emperor of roman the
emperor of persia they have all this
white expanse and you're sleeping on the
floor
he goes
out on you he would expand your abode
like you make the prophet at that stage
he actually responded he said i'm not
interested why should i it's mata dunya
this is uh
it's not the thing i want because we the
hereafter and the eschaton and all that
kind of thing
now
long story short
of the quran actually came down for this
now why was the prophet secluding from
all the wives because they were actually
asking him
to to give him money that he didn't have
that's why in sura
that the ayah came down which said that
if you want the the
the the the adornments of this world
then come and i will set you free and so
on
so there was an it was actually a choice
given to the wives of the prophet if you
didn't want to be with me then you can
go and it would actually be effective
and an effectual divorce
they had the choice many things can be
extrapolated from this hadith
number one the prophet didn't really
engage
with
the dominating uh
kind of discourse that um
came with
because actually in other places
the prophet muhammad has been described
in a hadith
he was actually very easy going and he
wasn't he if anything
he wasn't some
the hadith
say that he was more easy going than the
people of quraish like people like
some say that he didn't fit into that
category of people that used to try and
dominate his wife and so on he was very
easy going
which by the way flies in the face of
some of the discourses that we're seeing
in these manosphere spaces where they
think that the way to control your woman
and so on is to basically be obnoxious
and overly extroverted and so on there's
a time and a place for everything and
really there's no there's almost no time
in the place for that and the prophet
saw that was not his manage
however he didn't do nothing
he wasn't just taking abuse
he wasn't just uh you know accepting
and i'm not saying that they were even
abusing him quite frankly but he wasn't
accepting these complaints and demands
from his wives
how did he manage
the behavior of his wives
really you can call this anxiety
accrument method
and really in islam this is referred to
as
something
when you say you take an oath that i'm
not going to see my wife for x amount of
time and you have up to four months
and this is the way that you create a
healthy balance in the relationship
because when that anxiety starts to
accrue and it will accrue on both sides
i mean if a man is doing this anxiety
will accrue for him as much as it will
accrue for her
and that in that situation is a useful
moment of reflection
it's a use m useful and it's more useful
than being in a toxic situation in the
household where you're both shouting at
each other and there could be potential
for clash and destruction and fighting
and so on so this was the way
in which through which and by which the
prophet sallallahu decided to deal with
serial complaining
of nine women let's say sorry to say
which were his wives and they did
complain and he didn't just sit there
and take the complaints there's there's
a limit to complaints yes there's a
limit to complaints in islam
but then there's something we we must as
men acknowledge as well
number one
it was very clear that the behavior of
the qurashi woman were sorry the ansari
woman were affected by the korashi woman
oh sorry the opposite yeah so in other
words the fact
that some women can become emboldened by
other women is not something which is
because of the feminist movement this
was happening centuries before feminism
even
was
existed number two
you could even say that there are some
trends some cross-cultural continuities
in female collective temperament
that existed
in such a place of 7th century arabia
which is not explicable by ideological
reductionism
and therefore it's important for us to
realize that not everything is because
of feminism that a woman can be can be
behaving in a certain way
simply because of psychological
temperament
not because she's infected infected
influenced by the feminist
movement or feminist ideology it's not
always the reason so we have to be more
nuanced because if it's the case that
even the highest of women can be
influenced by one another in the
negative
and that that brings them
to act in a behaviorally unacceptable
way
then
or
from logical reasoning and analogy
sorry to say women that are not
their wives prophets are going to act in
a very similar way and that's why the
prophet muhammad he said
a woman is not going to be with you
on one way she's not going to give you
one mood you you'll find
that there is a tempestuous and
tumultuous way through which by which
some women uh interact with their
husbands and that is something we have
to accept because accepting this means
that our expectations will be realistic
you don't get married and think oh she
has to be completely submit there's no
such thing as a totally uh infallible
woman that's going to do everything you
want every time you want however having
said that the prophet didn't just take
sorry to say this behavior
lying down
there was a reaction and what kind of
reaction was it was it shouting and
swearing and pushing and no no no no
it was a reaction whereby it removed
himself from the situation he done this
thing called
which is sanctioned in the quran which
is the right of a man and not the right
of a woman because the man is the kawam
of the woman which means that he has a
certain authority that the woman does
not have a moon
father
that men have a degree of
managerial capability of a woman so
clearly there are some things that are
put in place for the man to be able to
control a otherwise tumultuous situation
and the prophet
opted for that which would
force a person into a state of
reflection
force a person to be grateful force a
person to be uh respectful and then when
he did come back 29 days later
to his wives the situation was amended
so this is the way to deal with the
situation and so we take inspiration
from the prophet muhammad
on how
to manage and mitigate the situation
uh of gender relations with our wives
and uh i'm sorry to say
so too should
the
uh women of today muslim women of today
look at this yet
for a realistic guide yes they made
their mistakes but they come back from
them that's why in the quran it stated
in tatum
that allah had made it easy for you to
do tawba and of course they did make
tawba which means they come back and
they recognize their faults and then
cohesion can happen and stability of
families can happen but so much can be
seen in this hadith by way of gender
relations
in conclusion not everything is related
to feminism sometimes it's to do with
the female collective temperament
and we also as men need to have the
right expectations women need to
also have the right expectations
and that will be that and i thought it
would be very interesting to look at
that uh inject a position with some of
the work that we've already done on
ideology and hopefully that was
beneficial
what if you are dying from
thirst and hunger would you give your
iman up your faith up in order
to survive probably not probably not
because you'd rather die
in hunger and thirst than give up your
religion right
this is how much we value our faith it's
priceless brothers and sisters let me
introduce you to norway this is a
european country where the vast majority
of people have become irreligious there
are 200 000 muslims of a population of
about 5 million and most of these 200
000 muslims have no idea how to explain
islam to their non-muslim friends and
neighbors but that needs to change allah
sent his messenger to call people to
eternal success and that is why muslims
in norway are now establishing a masjid
and dawa center to enhance the norwegian
tawa but they cannot do this alone we
need to support them if you donate to
the schools you will insha allah reap
the rewards of thousands of muslims
coming back to islam and many of those
will become dwight and invite to islam
you will share in the reward for all
those shahadas and good deeds to come
insha'allah so click the link and donate
now and share the video for extra reward